hi I'm Dan Radcliffe and I am here with
BuzzFeed today reading thirsts tweets
just found out last night what thirst
tweets actually means I thought it was
as tweets that were in some way thirsty
for attention not the attention was
specifically sexual so this will be fun
I believe in magic and that magic is
Daniel Radcliffe's abs that's very kind
if you can hear somewhere else little
thing of this that is my girlfriend
Daniel Radcliffe with a beard is my kink
well lucky you this is this is this is a
real boon for you then this one that
says Daniel Radcliffe I would totally
let him Slytherin that's a classic Harry
Potter based sexual thing I like to
think it wouldn't be much of it I
wouldn't really be a slipper
that's a are you really gay you didn't
Google Daniel Radcliffe back was naked
back then well that is a question I wish
Daniel Radcliffe would send me nudes so
I could screen print them on a Snuggie
that has both filthiness to it and an
innocence my girlfriend's have said she
would take that snuggly so she agrees
with you personally interested in I lick
Daniel Radcliffe's eyebrows and body
assortments but could he started with
the eyebrows I feel like by the other
assortments she means the rest of my
hair which is great thank you I've
always been very very self-conscious
about my crazy eyebrows so it's it's
that's nice to know they're going down
well out there
honestly Robert Pattinson telling Daniel
Radcliffe to take a hot bath taught me
all worked up highly I actually you know
it's been a very long time since I've
seen the before film I had forgotten but
that was a thing have happened but if as
you say it does then then yeah I want
Daniel Radcliffe to punch my tongue with
his tongue I am without commenting on
the act itself I really like how it's
phrased tongue punches is a great new
name for kisses Daniel Radcliffe is a
small soft boy who I want to wrap in a
blanket and protect but at the same time
he's got big energy I want to ride him
like a fireball thank you to you I know
I liked that it ended well but I'm still
no Chan of a small self-glory Akio
Daniel Radcliffe's dick for those of you
who don't know that it's a summoning
spell from the Harry Potter books and
films Daniel Radcliffe and more like
Daddy Radcliffe am i right ladies
I heard the daddy thing really well
thanks still sincerely
thank you daniel radcliffe could do that
spell to spread my legs my knowledge of
off-the-cuff Latin is not as good enough
to be able to like to come up with what
that spell would be right now I'm fairly
sure that was not featured in the books
then arackliffe is my daddy hmm you with
that wizard daddy in my industry HMU
stands for hair and makeup
hit me up Oh hit me ah hit me up you
want me to hit you up with that wizard
and then you call me daddy again
I don't like this daddy came guys I
don't even care Daniel Dracula could
taught me like a little jetpack any day
well that's very kind of you
thank you very generous daniel radcliffe
good Heike choke me and I would love it
great bang that's back thank you for
introducing me to the word Heike just to
be clear I would totally lick daniel
records also to test if it was delicious
that is a reference to something which
like can justify I only appear on a
cards against humanity' for that for
anyone who has pulled it and I have I
have signed quite a few of these cards
is references references that fall of my
body thank you all for your interest
this has been fascinating guys I think I
might have to just like put a text on to
my parents saying they don't mean to
walk my buzzfeed into jail for everybody
out there take me the woman but my beard
is a king go watch Kimi versus the
Reverend when it comes out on Netflix
it's an interactive special and I'm in
it and I have at it so yeah enjoy
[Music]